the next body type we're going to talk
about is going to be called the adrenal
now the adrenal gland sits on top of the
kidney right here you got two of them go
ahead and put your fingers on your
adrenals now the adrenal gland is a
stress gland how many of ever
experienced stress before got one two
three four five six give me an example
what stresses people out work traffic
children kids husbands being overweight
school relationships like finances well
you guys can relate to that how many
have ever had a stressful relationship
before at least once twice okay we'll
stop right there so the adrenal reacts
and adapts the body to stress so if you
pretend like you're being chased by a
tiger for the next 10 years and how your
body would react to that that's what
happens with the adrenals over time when
it burns out well if you're being chased
by a tiger you're not gonna be able to
sleep okay you're not gonna be able to
reproduce so you're going to have
problems with hormones reproductive
hormones you're going to problems with
digestion you're going to problems with
blood pressure and cholesterol and all
these other things with blood sugars
because you're running on sugar so I'm
going to go through all of them but the
adrenals regulate stress and stress does
accumulate yes you're like a bucket and
you filled up in fact there is always
some stress that has occurred right
before you started developing a stubborn
weight issue always if you ask a person
they think it's just calories right well
if you take it back when did you start
gaining weight what happened just before
that you're going to find that they had
a baby c-section a surgery a
hysterectomy tubal ligation they got
married they got a divorce on that same
date now they have just a lot of
different stresses I've had people even
as kids be be overweight and many times
it comes after an asthma attack or us
our ear infection or
infection so many things that can stress
the body out but stress does accumulate
and over time you develop too many
applications on your desktop computer
which is your body so all these things
accumulate and you're just like a bucket
of stress you're some people when we
measure the inside of you are so jacked
up they can't sleep they can't relax so
I would say probably the biggest thing
that stresses people out are other
people is that true there's certain
personality types that kind of get to
you you got the whiner
right there like will you please help me
when you please help me do the ever
accept your help now you just want to
help you just want to like okay let me
push you downstairs now do you want my
help so it's like you have whiners you
have the antagonistic person who's rude
you have the real depressed person that
brings you down you'll give them a
solution they say no that will never
work or you have those really happy
people that are always just happy that
doesn't stress me out but sometimes it's
like if you're depressed you don't
really like these happy people they're
just too positive all the time but
there's one personality type that really
gets on my nerves and they call it the
passive-aggressive called under minors
now let me show you what they what they
look like so everyone look at me very
very hostile right now you're smiling
look at me very mean okay now smile hi
nice to meet you
they're gonna backstab you to your face
they told you they stood up for you but
they actually ruin your reputation
they love gossip how many v'n know
anyone like that they give you a
compliment but they follow it up with a
sharp critical comment
they'll say something like hey that's a
nice jacket was it on sale like who
would ever say that psycho that's a nice
haircut
did you get at cheap cuts my uncle I
mean actually yes it was my uncle he
goes congratulations you graduated as a
chiropractor
gratulations hey why don't you wanna
become a real doctor
so you have people that are bringing you
up and people that bringing you down
right so those people they bring you
down covertly so they're very
introverted they'll they'll do something
like this are you feeling okay you look
really tired are you sick
and you're like I was fine until you
said that so I do have a way of getting
back at these people if you'd like to
know about that anyone want another
technique okay just reverse the flow
just do back to them have you has that
been growing for a while you don't have
anything in the face they'll be in the
bathroom for hours looking at their face
going is there anything on here because
they're introverted you so yeah okay so
let's move on to something less
stressful but if you're in a
relationship like that or someone's
connected and you're trying to reason
with them don't hold your breath
you can't reason with them that's what
frustrates you because you just want to
get them to see can't you see that
you're crazy now they're not going to
see that they have to be right they'd
rather be right then successful so you
just better off just ignoring them
okay so adrenal when the adrenal gland
gets burnt out your tolerance for stress
goes down you don't tolerate people
anymore people get on your nerves you
become edgy especially incompetent
people people that make mistakes you
kind of like you might react more than
you should right you're not going crazy
okay
it's the adrenals because the tolerance
of stress you ability to tolerate stress
stuff this kind of buffers it so
sometimes that buffer goes down and
you're and you're just kind of on edge
all the time the way you think it's not
linear it's like popcorn thoughts just
come in like this your memory starts the
adrenal affects the GPS in the brain so
it's kind of like you're going on stairs
you're like um what am I looking for
again got a backtrack okay you'll be
talking to some of it you're actually
having another conversation in your head
you might be waiting for the person to
stop talking so you can talk because
you're
kind of thinking too fast it's going too
fast what you're doing you're solving
problems 24/7
you can't stop solving problems in fact
you can't stop thinking so with adrenal
they do a lot of thinking and because
they're in a survival mode it's called
flight or fight mode that is a the
problem with that is it stirs up the
adrenals even more what they should be
doing is just turn it off or at least I
don't know like a half hour a day go for
a walk look at a tree a bird a cloud and
just get space don't get the headphones
on and you know look at your computer
all the time how many of you sit in
front of a computer more than five hours
a day 16 hours a day Wow
that what happens is that it really kind
of the computers everything kind of will
stress your body - especially if you
have the computer right next to your
body I would try to get as far away as
possible and even when you go to sleep
at night make sure there's no electrical
stuff right by your head you got cell
phones you know all that stuff I'm very
sensitive to energies and I can pick up
like I don't like talking in that cell
phone somehow it just like feels like
there's a microwave in my brain so I'm
like okay I gotta go you know just
that's why everyone's like what's your
cell phone number I never pick it up
because I don't like that cell phone so
the adrenal when the adrenal gets
stressed you can't tolerate stress and
you start increasing hormones that are
going to cause belly fat all right so
this is an adrenal body type shape right
here the weight is right there now why
is it in the belly primarily because
your body's in survival and as a stress
mechanism you're going to hold it around
the most important organs which happen
to be in your midsection your body's
trying to survive it's trying to help
you it's protecting you against
starvation that low-calorie diet that
you're going to go on yeah so it's like
going to put it right here how many
sit-ups will it take to flatten that
belly it's not going to happen why
because it's coming from a hormone your
problem is not your weight it's your
hormones
you have to reduce that cortisol the
things that people do to lose weight end
up destroying their metabolism and their
hormones we don't want to jack that up
anymore so people take stimulants you're
already stimulated you don't want to
jack it up more so it goes there now
over time instead of burning the belly
fat off as energy it's going to burn off
your leg muscles before it even touches
that fat in other words your body is
going to use up your proteins and your
little in your thighs so guess what
that's connected to your knees that's
why you have a lot of knee problems with
with adrenal and you have a lot of
collagen because all the the glue that
holds about it together falls apart so
you have loose skin
it's called pendulous abdomen it kind of
sags right here and when you get it from
a seated position you're kind of like
getting up climbing is a problem your
legs are heavier don't wear it gets
worse so after these legs become
dissolved then your adrenals will go
after another muscle called the
gluttonous a Maximus what muscle is that
you're behind so so what happens is not
only do we get us thinner legs and
bigger trunk but we get no but so get no
but no legs all belly you've seen people
like that right so you have somebody
look forward to I'm just I'm telling you
you got it you have to kind of start now
just preventing okay I've had relatives
that before menopause oh my goodness
wastes like this after like that so yeah
so adrenal glands will cause all sorts
of problems with stress responses and it
affects their ability to sleep normally
when you go to sleep at night you're
supposed to go through four waves of
sleep from a light sleep here to a deep
sleep here now down here in the lower
parts this is called the Delta wave
sleep right here
that's where you burn 90% of all your
fat not during the day all the fat
burning
kurz right there if you're not sleeping
you're not going to burn fat but in your
mind you're thinking you're wasting your
time I should be walking while I'm
sleeping just to burn off those calories
so let's talk about calories for a
second
yes exercise does burn calories that's
true but not necessarily fat calories
let's take a look at something when a
normal person exercises they they
actually stress their body out okay it
sounds pretty interesting but what all
the benefit from that exercise occurs in
the recovery 14 hours just 24 hours
later when you're in the deep sleep if
you're sleeping if you let yourself
recover you ever hear that workout
called the p90x or the insanity workout
I normally see people like 45 they start
doing that you ever see the videos they
have like 18 year-olds if you have low
recovery like low endurance low Fitness
and you do that something that hot
you're going to hurt yourself
you're going to pull a hamstring I see
it all the time my son I took them to
wrestling practice and he's like 16 17 I
was wrestle in college we go there and
all the fathers are around the mat
they're standing around the perimeter
with their shoes off with her socks on
waiting to jump in there because they're
in their mind they're still 18 one guy
breaks a rib this guy you know he runs
out of almost like had a heart attack it
was hilarious so mentally you might
still be 18 physically you may not be
quite that level so it really all the
benefit occurs in the recovery after the
workout so when you exercise you stress
your body and then you're supposed to
recover and that's when you burn the fat
not during the workout if you don't
believe me go work out three hours and
weight yourself before and after you'll
burn 900 calories but no actual weight
loss okay so it's all right here if you
can recover adrenal cases don't recover
that well so they don't adapt so the
exercise only as good as if you can
change
or adapt to it so that's really what
we're dealing with this how do you get
your body to change from the things
you're doing it
how many fun when you're 18 you can
pretty much eat anything you want really
you can just get away with it right
how many fun you can't quite get away
with it now what is the difference the
difference is your metabolism the rate
your metabolism okay that's really
what's broken
you really have to exercise based on
your ability to recover from it it's
better off through adrenals if you go
walking on a flat surface than to get on
that treadmill to burn off the calories
so the thing that people do cut calories
starvation exhaustive exercise is the
exact thing that's keeping that weight
there and they're frustrated because
they been taught that oh everyone knows
that you just have to exercise and diet
oh really well those people are saying
that have never probably worked with one
person I bet I've been there in the
field weight loss for 25 years I worked
on 35,000 different people I believe a
patient because I observe them they're
eating good and it's still not working
they're doing the treadmill still not
working so it really has to do with the
internal so we want to adjust the
workout to your ability to adapt that's
why you have to you can't put everyone
in the same program everyone needs their
own program so with adrenal either they
can't get to sleep because they're so
wound up and they can't relax because
they're thinking so much or they get up
in the middle of night like - and just
like they're more awake at 2:00 than
they are turning the day in fact right
after lunch or three o'clock they're
just ready to go to sleep so either they
can't get to sleep you can't stay sleep
or the bladder which actually is
controlled by the adrenal has to
eliminate you know so they're getting up
urinating several times a night
that's adrenal the best sleep for the
adrenal is a half hour before the alarm
clock goes off right there right when
you finally get to sleep that's when you
got to get out there can anyone relate
to that yeah don't worry it gets worse
so we got the adrenal will affect the
sleep create an inability to see change
from a workout and
it also will affect your cognitive it
affects a lot of other things as well it
affects blood pressure yeah that's one
of the symptoms from the adrenal is high
blood pressure especially of the top
number the systolic before the diastolic
so always look at the top number if the
top top note is high we know it's
adrenal so because your body's you lost
that recovery mechanism to kind of keep
the pressure down so you have blood
pressure we have blood sugar yes
diabetes is a symptom of adrenal because
they control the sugars blood
cholesterol is adrenal yeah cholesterol
is needed to make adrenal hormones
during stress the more stress you go
through the more cholesterol you need to
be able to build those hormones and then
you have all allergies our adrenal
including this sinus low vitamin D
levels are hard renal yeah I know your
doctor saying go take vitamin D
deficient but they're not asking why
okay
arthritis all the itis ha's in fact
anything connected with inflammation is
adrenal poor handwriting and that's me I
could write the first part of the word
but the last purpose kind of gets all
lost so what this means blood pressure
blood sugar blood cholesterol allergies
vitamin D inflammation and cognitive
issues and some Nia other than that
you're perfectly healthy now here is the
problem what happens is that the medical
system treats treats these they don't
ask why there's no evaluation what
they'll do is take that symptom
okay these are symptoms this is what
symptom is and then they make it the
problem okay they confuse the symptom
with the problem it's like one of those
obvious things I'm like is it just me
why is anyone asking this question
because if you ask your doctor what
caused this what they'll do is convert
it to a very scientific complex name
it you have Lum Belgium what does that
mean low back pain okay you have
fibromyalgia what does that mean you got
you're hurting all over your body you
have plantar fasciitis what does that
mean
you got pain in the foot you have dis
data Kinesis sounds pretty scientific
that means you can't do this with your
body you can't rotate it back and forth
you have spondylolysis what does that
mean you have a you have a broken back
there's all these labels post-traumatic
stress syndrome you means you you got
some stress in your past they have one
now called non-compliance to treatment
disorder I'm serious I'm not kidding
non-compliance to treat mis order if you
don't do what the doctor says I told my
son that and he said Oh homie don't play
that I'm like I said I said what does
homie don't play that mean he said that
means I'm not going to do what you say
like okay then you're going to get a
diagnosis from the doctor because he's
going to go you have non-compliance the
treatment story well maybe you didn't
want the surgery maybe you want to suck
opinion and they'll put this label they
have manic depressive what does that
mean it means that you're happy and sad
what's wrong with being happy you know
you have a clinical depression it could
mean that you're not sleeping people
that don't sleep get depressed so it's
just amazing and then it's treated with
a poison I'm sorry of medication my
whole thought is that what's really
missing in health care is the health
part it's kind of like that I mean I
don't know that sometimes I'm like did I
just think of that is that original idea
or does everyone know that I mean it's
bizarre there's no health and health
care it's all disease care there are
underlying principles to all subjects in
life that are very high principles that
everything kind of must revolve around
okay my whole principle and weight loss
is getting healthy lose weight not
losing weight to get healthy you have to
focus on your health now that's pretty
powerful because if you don't know that
you're very susceptible to the next
unhealthy diet that comes along or a
little guy
that might not be healthy but if you
look at it from the viewpoint of okay is
that healthy yes okay that might work
let's just take the word food how many
of you eat food okay yeah how many of
you never looked up the definition of
the word food before okay I'm going to
tell you what it is is that which is
eating to sustain life provide energy
and promote the growth and repair of
tissue it comes from the Latin word
which means nourishment nutrients so
food is nutrients that's why we supposed
to eat we're not supposed to eat food
for necessarily anything other than
health and nutrients but so when you go
into the grocery store you can ask now
what am I in the mood for no no no don't
ask that because you're going to get a
brownie but if you say what can get me
more nutrition what's what can I eat
that has more nutrition that's very
powerful because then you get it stay
out of trouble I guarantee all the junk
foods don't have a lot of nutrition they
don't other than synthetic vitamins in
politics you have underlying principles
that you use like that I guess the
principle and politics or the underlying
senior principle would be something like
them don't spend more than you have
right in the budget would that be kind
of a smart thing get out of trouble so I
guess we're not to worry about that one
just being sarcastic
and then you have what about in in the
area of health in general you have to or
health care you have to create your
health can you imagine if we just put 1%
of none of the money we put in sick care
or health care into just prevention or
creating health it's over it's over
I mean prevention the problem is the
doctors will say okay let's check in six
months okay and you keep coming back
let's check you let's check you sorry to
tell us you have cancer get your stuff
together and it's we're going to do
chemo what was to be done to prevent it
what was done to create the health
there's nothing what are they going to
do an aspirin a day I had to get life
insurance okay Reese I'm still trying to
figure out why my wife plan to get life
insurance
so I go to the doctor my cholesterol is
a 180 it's pretty good doctor says well
it's normal but we're going to prevent
we're going to we're going to practice
some preventive medication what what are
you talking about sir my gos I know but
we're just doing and everyone right now
I'm like no thank you no because no no I
have a free sample
lipitor I'm like now that a side effects
cuz oh now that's you can't believe the
articles you can't believe I'm like what
I can get a kickback so the point is
that there's a lot of corruption in the
area of pharmaceuticals and drugs you
already know that but the point is that
you have to start creating your health
because the doctors just don't know how
I trained doctors I trained over 2400
doctors they're not taught how to get
someone healthy other than the food
pyramid drink more water eat more fiber
you know it's just like it's not
significant so you really have to learn
how to create health yourself and start
building your health because no one else
is going to do it for you cancer takes
20 years to grow in your body I mean all
of you probably have some cancer cells
in your body it's what you're doing in
your environment that's countering that
right now to protect you you literally
you have to create your health every day
so I look at people a little differently
like what I'll do when I'm listening to
people I'll just dissect them in half
and I'll go okay what are the things
they're doing to create their health and
one of the things are doing to counter
create their health because doing
nothing is counter creating right so and
it's amazing it's it makes it so simple
I'm like wow like wow look at this like
you don't have you don't realize that
many people don't realize that the
cravings are a very simple nutrient
deficiency potassium when you have low
potassium you will crave sugar
guaranteed when you get your daily
amount of potassium you will not crave
sugar it's that simple how many of the
crave sugar okay if I tell you what to
do would you would you do it to get rid
of cravings within 24 hours or actually
48 hours okay so do this thing right
here normal amount of potassium we need
is 4700 milligrams a day
now what food are is high in potassium
bananas right that's 400
okay how many bananas will it take
twelve twelve bananas right so you're
not going to do twelve bananas okay so
the amount of potassium you need is so
high you don't even realize it there's a
lot of potassium so what you can do is
you can have all the leafy greens you
would need seven cups to seven cups it's
not hard couple salads a day and you
will fulfill your daily amount
requirement for potassium you won't you
will not have cravings it's wonderful to
help protect against diabetes this right
here because when you have that
potassium and helps stabilize your blood
sugars but how many of you really don't
consumed seven cups of salad or day
hardly anyone does how the heck are you
ever going to get your potassium so this
is the problem is we don't really know
what foods have the right nutrients and
and the soils are so depleted if you
would if you wanted to get your basic
nutrients of trace minerals okay those
are little minerals that you need in
small amounts in your food right now
with the soils the way they are you
would have to consume 27,000 calories of
food yeah so that's going to be pretty
hard isn't it that's a lot of food
eating every day so you're going to have
to sub sort of enhance your diet with
something just make sure it's the right
nutrients plant-based you have to
concentrate but yeah that's this is the
problem is that people don't know how to
create health and so it's kind of crazy
so so we have the adrenal we have with
the problem with the adrenal is you get
fluid retention because all the
electrolytes are controlled the sodium
potassium is controlled by the adrenal
in other words when you have adrenal
problems you lose potassium your salts
and elect all these things that keep the
fluid moving are gone so the fluids
going to pull in your ankles when you
press your ankle that leaves a little
dent that's fluid retention you
shouldn't have that okay go ahead and
press your ankle and see if you have any
indentations there can you call 9-1-1
so fluid in the ankles is purely
electrolyte problem because the adrenal
it's backing up fluid so we had that
we're going to salt cravings for adrenal
to salt cravings
that's adrenal stall is the is the
mineral that recharges the battery
that's why you need a little chip at
night when you go home I mean just to
recharge your battery because you're
drained most of you are like a car in
the freeway the battery is dead and
you're putting gas in the car why isn't
this thing start now you're pushing the
car it's getting kind of heavy so
electrolytes fluid now how much water
should you drink a class is right who
told you that they told you some day I'm
going to find out and the bay is because
that is a myth I was taught to drink I
still can't find the where do you find
this information only drink when you're
thirsty here's what I found the more
water you drink the more dehydrated you
become why because it flushes out the
electrolytes that are supposed to hold
the water there there's a condition
right now that I think it's called
hyponatremia which is actually too much
water which is flushing electrolytes and
you can die died by drinking too much
water so drink when you're thirsty I
have a machine I measure fluid in
person's body normally people that drink
the most water the most dehydrated don't
worry it gets worse so they is
everywhere it's nowhere it's like I
don't know who they is so you have
fluids we have calcium calcium is
controlled by the adrenal not just bone
loss not just muscle cramps but you need
calcium to have to wind down at night
without good adrenals your calcium will
deposit not in the bone but on the bone
as arthritis bursitis tendinitis tartar
no teeth cataracts
kidney stones gall stones bursitis all
the itis is and twitching and the left
eyelid right here yeah that's calcium so
again what do people take calcium
limestone it's in the one-a-days anytime
you get a vitamin that's prescribed
prescription at a pharmacy oh my
goodness that's like how low can you go
it's just way off the deep end it's just
going to be rocks you need plant-based
minerals this is how it works
the plant is supposed to break down the
minerals like rocks in earth and absorb
them into the plant and make them easy
to digest the plant-based minerals are
ten thousand times smaller than rocks
and metallic minerals that you would get
like sea salts yeah ten thousand times
smaller so that would be the equivalent
to a a golf ball to the Empire State
Building
so you absorb these plant-based minerals
so much better you find that when you
eat food you don't feel satisfied like
it just doesn't quite even water just
doesn't satisfy you because the
nutrients aren't there why do you think
you keep craving so it's just it's a
deficiency so we have sinus problems oh
that's another diagnosis sleep apnea
what does that mean it means that your
sinuses are blocked like very I mean
it's just amazing how it's gotten out of
control and so right now the answer to
health care is not spending more money
on it it's just to do more prevention
the whole philosophy is broken but
there's no money in prevention it's too
cheap I mean it's very cheap in fact I
can take every one of your grocery bills
and probably find $100 every two weeks
of a food that you could just switch
over to the healthier food and just in
and just take that in great health it's
not that hard it's just choices what to
eat in the grocery store why do I know
this because I go in the grocery store
and I see what they have so bad it's
amazing like wow people must be buying
that because it's there and then trying
to find food and grocery store it's not
easy it's like um so we have adrenal any
other question about the adrenal body
type
it's kind of an interesting type
snoring because the sinuses there's a
nerve that goes in the back of the
sinuses that if the adrenal gland
shrinks it because the cortisol and it
actually makes this thicker so you like
you know snoring so we have adrenal now
the other thing is that of course my
wife's is that sometimes I make that
sound I'm like no I don't she goes okay
I'm going to record you I'm like okay
you can prove it so that's adrenal